dans tous nos territoires orinois
l'économie et l'emploi sont des éléments
très importants euh sur notre canton de
Cerny on a la chance de pouvoir
bénéficier de de sites touristiques
importants et structurants pour notre
économie locale euh nous sommes ici au
Markstein euh qui est géré par un
syndicat mixte qui inclut le département
et deux communautés de commune et le
Markstein a la chance de pouvoir
justement euh offrir à notre économie
locale de l'emploi on a une soixantaine
d'emplois sur le site en hiver
particulièrement l'hiver c'est les
remontées mécaniques c'est la raquette à
neige c'est le ski de fond c'est de la
découverte aussi tout simplement et en
été bah c'est la randonnée c'est le
passage d'un axe touristique majeur qui
est la route des crêtes c'est le vol
libre donc avec le le parapante et et le
deltaplan c'est du du ski à roulette
pour certains c'est beaucoup de
randonnées bien entendu et tous ces
éléments font que on a une économie
touristique importante sur notre site
euh le tourisme c'est quoi c'est de
l'hébergement c'est du transport c'est
de la restauration et c'est des
activités de loisirs je vous ai parlé
des activités de loisirs qui sont
importantes nous avons également eu la
chance de pouvoir mettre en œuvre une
lche sur ail que vous pouvez apercevoir
derrière moi et qui satisfait pleinement
la la clientèle touristique mais
également notre clientèle locale et
quand on parle d'économie touristique je
vous disais tout à l'heure on parle
restauration sur les crêtes nous avons
encore la chance d'avoir de des
établissements intéressants qui
accueillent les randonneurs nous avons
également nos fermes auberges euh qui
sont dans la tradition et qui offrent à
la clientèle touristique à la clientèle
des des randonneurs en particulier un
accueil marquire un accueil qui qui fait
vraiment le le plaisir de de tout un
chacun et quand on parle route descêtes
quand on parle haute Chaum on parle bien
entendu environnement protection de la
nature et s'il y a un message à faire
passer je crois que le message le plus
important c'est de pouvoir dire que
environnement et tourisme sont tout à
fait
compatibles on peut développer le
tourisme dans le respect de
l'environnement dans le respect d'un
beau cadre de vie sachant que le cadre
de vie c'est le l'élément majeur qui
fait venir les gens ils veulent voir de
beaux paysages ils veulent voir des
paysages entretenus si ces paysages là
sont entretenus c'est grâce à nos
fermiers aubergistes et à nos
agriculteurs qui travaillent sur les
hautes chaumes et je crois que tout cela
concourt à faire de nos paysages des
paysages beaux intéressants accueillant
et à développer notre économie
touristique donc nous sommes à présent
sur le site du barrage de de CRUD de
villenstein qui est une propriété
départementale mais dont la gestion est
confiée à un syndicat mixte euh le
barrage est un atout pour notre économie
touristique en dehors de de sa fonction
de de régulateur de cru et
de stockage d'eau pour l'activité
industrielle on a une énorme activité
touristique sur le site avec différentes
pratiques le vélo bien entendu la
randonnée vous avez du canotage un peu
de pédalau mais également un espace
forestier qui abrite un parc d'arbre en
arbre une tyrolienne et sur la morine
qui jouxte le barrage vous avez le le
château du schlosberg enfin les ruines
du château du schlosberg qui font
actuellement l'objet euh d'une remise en
en état si l'on peut dire avec une
association locale d'insertion
patrimoine et emploi euh qui s'applique
à à remettre à jour quelques vestiges du
château et on dispose d' sur ce site
d'une vue extraordinaire sur la vallée
de
laat